after many requests a lot of time and a
lot more requests to finally watched and
finish daredevils so yeah we get to talk
about daredevil and that's the Netflix
series daredevil not the Affleck
daredevil so daredevil is a Netflix
original series if you haven't been
paying attention I'll let you know
Netflix is kind of killing it a lot of
quality programming on Netflix so now
they're gonna bring the Marvel Cinematic
Universe into Netflix as Marvel
Cinematic syriza's is the daredevil is
about a lawyer who's blind who is a
superhero that goes out an item fights
crime oversimplification maybe but yeah
it's pretty much it but he has like
extra senses you know we can walk in a
room and he knows where everything is
and what's in the room which is a really
cool premise honestly I mean you know
Stan Lee did that [ __ ] on purpose
justice is blind and Daredevil's blind
you know Stan Lee when making this [ __ ]
was just like me he's a blind superhero
so of course we're gonna make him a
lawyer because you know justice is blind
it just makes a lot of sense and it
would be right it doesn't make sense and
the good part is the show makes you
completely buy it was watching this and
I felt like if I really concentrated and
meditated a lot and honed my skills I'd
be able to walk in a room with a
blindfold on and know where everything
is be like there's a bar sub over there
on the sink I wouldn't be able to but I
love it when a show does that and brings
me into being a kid again like when you
watch The Matrix for the first time and
you really felt like you can jump off a
roof and land on the pavement on your
feet and be fine don't try that and
badly for you but when something like
this makes you by the fact this blind
lawyers out there kicking ass I love
that and they're not high-class lawyers
either now Matt Murdock who is daredevil
and his partner foggy they're a budget
law firm they're not the creme de la
creme now they're just trying to get
their name out saul goodman's like you
guys are some all-time but after
watching the first episode of this show
you know you're in for something special
the show is just so gritty and not that
you know like cliche where everything
has to be dark Ruston is dark I'm saying
it's real and I like it because it
should be real his costume really isn't
the daredevil costume it's this really a
simplified version of kind of a ninja
costume and I personally love that
costume because you feel like you could
do that again not only do you feel like
you could have your extra senses if you
really practice at it but you feel like
you could get that costume and go out
there and fight crime
other things try to do that like you
like the amazing spider-man one and they
were like we wanted to make a costume
that looks like someone like Peter
Parker could make and they did succeed
in that but in the end you look at her
like I'm never going to be able to make
something like that so it doesn't really
pertain to me Daredevils costume I could
buy that on eBay right now and it is
tied to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
after the whole events of the Avengers
you know a lot of real estate got wiped
out too now there are people out there
going to take advantage of this
opportunity to rise to power
enter Wilson Fisk played by Vincent
D'Onofrio Wilson Fisk is what you know
is the kingpin and I'm gonna be honest
with you I didn't know that much about
the kingpin other than what I saw in the
mid-90s spider-man cartoon and and that
was like yeah kingpins collected he's
calm he's the kingpin he's exactly what
you would think the kingpin would be of
a guy called the kingdom but this take
on the kingpin is really fascinating the
dude is calm and collected knows what to
say to people when he's shakin the hands
when he's trying to relate to a person
one-on-one like at an emotional level
he's kind of a socially awkward dude the
Edgar voice from men and black starts
coming out when kingpin starts feeling
awkward in the conversation he's all
like Thank You Wesley I truly appreciate
you tending to the matter and then
sometimes he rages out like a man-child
and beat someone to death and you're
like are you not in control of your
emotions but it adds layers to him I
mean you don't want this kingpin to be
this calm collected guy all the time
like I'm the kingpin it's like oh yeah
you mean you're a villain we've seen a
hundred times before
not just I'll switch that to thousands
it's thousands of times before but
there's one episode that primarily deals
with Wilson Fisk you're like yeah dude
you got problems what they ended up
doing they gave him layers and they made
him a human and you look at Wilson Fisk
you're like you're one of the more human
villains I've seen in a long time in
anything I love it when the show does
that in the end guys daredevil is one of
the smartest pieces of superhero cinema
I've seen in a very very long time they
had the elements of Batman Begins that
you loved along with the elements of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe that you also
loved it has a great relatable hero a
great relatable crew that works together
with them an awesome villain the good
part is it's not a movie so it's not
this huge thing the stakes are going up
against are very personal for them this
is like Matt Murdock's world at his
personal level he doesn't want this
Wilson Fisk [ __ ] to burn it to the
ground it's really opened my eyes to
bring you superheroes to other outlets
other than the movie theaters a lot of
people should look at this and be like
oh you mean we could do okay I guess
we'll do that
hang our hat on just movies and if
something might not work for a movie we
just won't see it as a dumbass mindset
daredevil shows us that I don't
generally speaking rate shows because
it's just too hard to do at this point
daredevil has my seal of approval I
marathon that [ __ ] I had a great time
with it and I really believe you will do
alright guys so daredevil on Netflix
have you seen it what did you think
about it wherever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you wanna
see more click right here to see more